[Music]
well good afternoon everybody
good afternoon everybody
well it's great to be back here it's my
third time here and it's it sounds great
to be back to the GSB I'm here today to
talk about how leaders and high
performance culture connects I'm sure
you all our leaders have been leaders or
prepare yourselves to be leaders and you
all want because you're here to do
things that are best-in-class high
performance so I'm here to to talk to
you in our experience all those things
connect first let me try to to share
with you our definition of leadership
because there's so many let me give you
a very simple one first we we started
thinking many years ago in a company I
mean okay leadership something is
important but our leaders born or forms
that forever question and we said okay
let's let's take the side of that we can
form leaders because people that say
that they're born leaders say that only
2% of the population are on that side so
let's believe that we can form leaders
because that will give us more
opportunities to find those guys within
our company second thing we said who is
a leader in our company and we said
anybody who has an objective at Target
and for him or her to get there
he needs a team he's in the leadership
position okay if tomorrow he's in the
spreadsheet and he's all by himself or
herself he's not in a leadership
position but he steps back into a
position where I need my team to get
somewhere he needs to play that role of
leader and now that gets us to the
definition of leadership leadership
something very simple to define very
hard to live what's the definition three
things is about delivering results on a
sustainable basis through the team so
the whole thing about the people aspect
you can't do it by yourself by the very
definition of literature
do it the right way so how we do it how
you do it that matters as much as what
you do it and I'm here today to explore
those three dimensions with examples in
our experience in how a leader can
affect those things there are many more
things about leaders you can say leaders
are people that are cannot be selfish
they have to think that it's not about
their ego it's not about him or her it's
about the company they're there to build
something much bigger not their ego to
resonate but the company also leaders
have to be somebody some people that are
people person they need to believe they
need to like to be surrounded by people
they need to to like to inspire people
to to get people to believe that they
can perform better than they think they
can that they together can get to places
that they never thought they could
that's inspiration that's coaching
that's making people believe giving them
reasons to believe it's always that
thing of up in the bar a leader is also
somebody who has to know enough details
about the operation to ask relevant
questions and to set targets that make
sense because some people believe that
as you grow in the company you have to
become more strategic that operations
something that for the lower guys and
you have to be strategic in our view
that misses the point a leader has to be
a mix of course I mean it's just like in
a ship in a big ship if everybody is in
is in the engine room and there's nobody
looking toward the ships going that's
not ideal if everybody's at the bridge
and nobody looking at the engine that
also doesn't work so of course there are
different roles and different mixes
between details of operations and
strategic side of the business but a
leader that's a hundred percent strategy
will not be able as time goes by because
it's getting distance from the business
to ask good questions and set relevant
targets so in our company we value
people that can have both and when
people come to meetings with me they
know I can dive in into any of the
details because I'm not afraid of it
because I travel I try to get as much
detail as
need to follow through things so again
lots can be said about leadership but
for us it's about achieving results with
the team doing it right and now I'm
gonna explore those three dimensions
I'll start with the first one which is
all about the dream what we call the
dream so if you're saying you need to
achieve great results you don't want to
achieve just average results you achieve
great results we call it and you need to
inspire people we call it you need to
give people a dream a sense of purpose
something that will inspire people will
get them to put their energy will get
them to really believe they can get
their role in the same direction
align the company it's easy to explain
to any of us what a dream is a dream
something that's stretched but credible
something that will require a lot of
work something that motivates everybody
and something that everybody can see how
I can you know with my bit of the
business help the company get there so
it's something that needs to talk to
everybody so it's a little bit of an art
form it's an educated art form on how to
set a dream that will talk to everybody
get everybody excited to go in the same
direction because if you can get there
and establish that dream then you up the
bar then you set the reference anything
below that it's not acceptable so if you
try to be best-in-class good it's not
good enough right and dreaming big takes
the same amount of energy as dreaming
small so why dream small takes the same
amount of energy so dream big inspire
your people and that will make amazing
things happen because people will start
believing it's just like the high jump I
mean if you always put the bar here
people just jump enough to clear the
hurdle if you start raising the bar and
people believe that they can do it and
they do it they start getting bad
confidence and they do it so that's the
thing about the big dream gets people to
be confident that they can deliver the
other thing is that you have to dream
big but you have to stay humble that's
very important because when you think
about it what what's the finish of a
dream
dream it's something where you say I'm
here I want to get here that's the dream
we called this a gap and for you to
determine a gap you have to find
somebody out there who serves as a
benchmark so you say the benchmarks here
we are here our dreams to close this gap
and then once this gap is closed you
open the next gap that's the only
function of a leader and management
management in general open gaps close
gaps but for you to open gaps you have
to be humble enough to believe that
there's always somebody out there
companies out there that do it better
than you do not in everything there's no
such a company a perfect company but in
every dimension supply chain logistics
finance legal people whatever you want
to call it there are three four five
companies out there they do it better
than you do
so think about trucks I mean the loading
of a truck
okay the routing systems you know the
warehouse management or think about
anything else you want to think
everything is measurable and if you can
measure you can compare to somebody else
and establish the gap so this is the
thing about being humble you have to
believe that no matter how good you
think you are there's always somebody
out there who is in specific dimensions
and in all dimensions do it better than
you not once somebody maybe somebody's
all you have to do is go look stablish
the benchmark open the gap and then the
whole thing and the targets and whole
systems about closing those gaps and
that covers the the first part in the
very summarized fashion of getting to
results in a sustainable way is to open
gaps have dreams get people excited and
make them believe that as a group that
can do much more than they believed they
could the high jump you keep putting
that bar higher and people start
believing because they do it that they
can do more things than they thought
they could all right are you guys with
me are you guys with me yes all right
okay so now let's go to the and to think
about the dream is this because some
companies you know you have that thing
called a feel-good Department I don't
know if you've heard about this one of
the companies we acquired many years ago
they had a department called the
feel-good depart
it was an invisible Department it was a
no work chart but it was everywhere and
every time they had a problem and a KPI
and a key performance indicator was not
being achieved they would send that
piece of news bad piece of news to the
few good department they would repackage
that send it back as a piece of good
news and everybody would be happy
was that amazing so the first thing we
got Theory said guys we need to close
this department and when things are
going well
they're good well we'll celebrate do
more of it when things are not going
well we'll call it a gap a problem
something we need to close and we always
said it's great to look up trying to
find that benchmark because when you
look up you get inspired you get
challenged if you're talented when you
look down you got comfortable and you
get lazy right it's the same thing I
mean if you come to the GSB you're
looking up because the people here will
raise the bar for you you'll say oh my
god this is very competitive if you go
to some other schools you feel great
it gave me the top 1% but is that gonna
be good for you no because it will get
you lazy and comfortable so you have to
get your group to look up find those
benchmarks open those gaps dream big and
go for it that's the first thing a
leader and high performance how they
connect the second thing is also the
whole thing about people when you think
about it there's no company what you
have is a group of people that equals a
company it's not the opposite the
company equals people know people equals
company so for you to have a great
company and a great leader want that
what's that you have to first have great
people the amazing thing about people is
that people is the only sustainable
competitive advantage any business can
have over competition can be a
consulting a banking in consulting and
bank it's easier to imagine because all
you have is people and telephones and
computers and frameworks and knowledge
at least that's what they say in
companies more like ours and others
where you have brands I mean people tend
to get distracted that what counts is
really the brands the factories the
warehouses the trucks the access to the
markets and forget the people components
but in our view again just like banking
consultant the most important things the
only sustainable competitive advantage
that is hard to copy as your people
machine the way you really grow people
attract retain grow develop deploy
that's hard to copy and people don't see
it sort of those soft things she
launched a new product that can be
copied next month the next day the next
six months should come if you have a new
marketing campaign that can be copied or
even done better but if you have a
people machine that get people to
develop and stay within your company and
grow and because they are the company
the company will grow as well that's
soft it's hard to see and when they see
it
you're already 5-10 years ahead of them
so people is very important for you to
dream big you need great people for you
to form a great company you need great
people and for you and the things that
great people attract more the same
that's the amazing thing they like to
work together they challenge each other
they learn from each other they get
inspired by each other the problem is
that made yogurt people also love to
work together they gave each other easy
targets right they think about it's
great they celebrate even when they have
no reasons to celebrate they use the
fuel department right and that builds a
an average company not a great company
great companies are for more great
people but the thing about great people
is not attracting great people
it's retaining great people because a
lot of companies that do a good job are
attracting great people but they lose
them they train them to the marketplace
we're not at school I'm gonna be
training people for our competitors to
use them we want people to come and stay
but for them to come and stay we don't
lose good people and when we do it's a
crisis we learned a couple of things
four or five things that I'll share with
you that talented people like you love
in a company some companies offer that
some others don't
first thing meritocracy easy to say hard
to do may Tucker's is that concept that
people grow according to their talents
what they can deliver the potential they
have the teams they form the people they
attract the culture ambassador the
culture they spread they grow because of
that not because of the passport last
names how long they've been in the
company now because of the first group
of things that's meritocracy very hard
in the Q&A we can explore more of that
but that's meritocracy a meritocracy is
hard to do because it entails the fact
of fairness artificial fairness is that
you have to treat different people in
different ways that's be fair if you
treat everybody the same that's unfair a
meritocracy is being fair so if somebody
is dedicating more time producing more
results have more protections is willing
to chew a bigger bone it's really to
have more accountability is we need to
go to places be transferred around the
globe that person deserves more
opportunity more exposure will have more
learning and will also build their
wealth according to the value that's
being created that's also very important
components it's not the most important
one by any stretch but it's one of the
components okay so the idea of fairness
is that you treat different people
different ways and a lot of companies
are afraid of saying that because that
sounds incorrect but at the end what's
incorrect is treating everybody the same
the second thing they like is this whole
idea about informality if a melt is not
the way you dress it's not the way you
set up your operations in terms of
offices and stuff for example in our
place which I have no office I have a
big table with my direct reports around
me and so does everybody you know places
in the world where we operate why
because information flow
people can speak up you don't need to be
booking meetings all the time it has
happened as you meet people in the
office
there's no assistant blocking your
agenda you're available that's a
formality but that's only part of it
the true informality is a company that's
able to deal with healthy conflict
conflicts and a lot of people don't like
that a lot of bosses don't like to be
contradicted or challenged what I say is
that as long as it's respectful and
constructive you can say whatever you
want if you're trying to get the
business to a better place and having no
hidden agendas help that that's why I
never go home with a work-related
problem I go home with the market
related problem so if in that market my
brands are not performing well
competition is kicking my you know what
that's something it's 24/7 with me but
if I go to a meeting somebody says
something that sounds strange to me I
won't go home with that after the
meeting I'll call Jane Jane can we talk
for five minutes ago to different room
you said that they quite didn't
understand did you mean a or B I meant a
o very good because I thought was B okay
up settled and then your mind is free up
again to focus on what matters well what
greats value and not on internal
politics and things like that an open
office also enables that people don't
have doors to close and talk small talk
it's all open so that's the formality
the whole thing about healthy conflicts
the other thing that talented people
like you like in a company is skander
honesty they want to know what they
stand example performance evaluation we
do it twice a year
formally 90 minutes 1-1 both ways
self-evaluation my evaluation of the
individual his or her evaluation of me 9
minutes it takes 90 minutes to get to
what counts okay
very easy to say very hard to do because
then it's a Friday and you say oh my god
if I have to tell Tong the things that
are not working
ruin his Wiccan and then the next week
you travel and then when you're back
his not here and then a years past ten
years past his life is only one and it's
short anyway all of our lives are short
for everything we want to do and you're
just playing God because you know
something and you don't want to share
it's his life it's wrong you have to
tell what's good what's bad and how you
can help him recover and get back on
track candor talented people like to
know where they stand their future with
the company what the next steps could be
and what they can do better
okay don't like you to manage that as
you know playing God and I'll do it my
way I don't need to share that then
they'll share with me it's my life I
want to know it another thing that they
like is this idea of partnership in our
company we have partners partners the
people up from a certain level up we
have partners they share in the wealth
that's created as a company we're not
share we're not shy of sharing we're off
that's created talented people like that
they like to know that if you work hard
and they do the things and they get the
results that part of those things
they'll also be able to share it's not
the most important thing but it's part
of the package so that's very key and
it's some companies people are very shy
they don't like to do that I think this
is important for talented people because
they feel that there is a wealth
creation going on along with the company
creating value the other thing they like
is growth I was in Mexico yesterday the
last two days we just acquired an
operation Mexico the grupo modelo the
corona brands module especial all those
grants our head of the Mexico operation
which is a zone as we call it we have
seven zones around the world is the
third important zone is a guy who's 35
years old as the head of our maximum
operation
it's his responsibility to integrate the
business make the tough decisions right
size of structure delivers the synergies
continue to grow the top-line get that
business to be one of our business and
implement the culture 35 so we're not
afraid of giving people early on in
their careers as much as they have a lot
of the things I described before you
know that they leapfrog others and they
get ahead because they're better that's
the thing about fairness he's better
than others so why wait
the third leg so I spoke about leaders
again deliver results with the people do
it the right way how you doing
okay that's what we call the culture of
the place guard mentioned this year as
we integrate many companies as we as we
grew organically and organically culture
was the first thing you know the first
thing I do when i acquire a company i go
there and i talk about dream people
culture that's it I don't talk about the
business about the seniors no I talk
about what we stand for because we
believe that culture has to do with
performance and performance cannot be
compromised with things like oh here's
different oh no no let me explain you
this that works in X country in Y
country here will not work I'm from
white country we've tried this before
don't buy into this one company one
culture a lot of mergers and
acquisitions don't go well because 10
years after you merged is to go to a
meeting and as Sam Brito from ABI and
you see I'm Jane from XYZ ten years
later that doesn't create value because
just you operate this two entities just
under one corporate umbrella so one
company one culture is key and what's
this culture I'm talking about is a
coach of ownership owners make better
decisions in our company we strive to
have an engaged group of owners look at
that an engaged group of owners versus a
selfish Bunch
of professionals professionals are just
trying to build a resume executives
owners are trying to build the company
something that's bigger than any of us
in the company something that will be
there forever that we can look back and
sales part of it I was proud of it my
name is in there
that's an owner an owner will stay with
the company for many years and because
of that we'll make better decisions
because the owner will live with the
consequences of the decisions the
executive who is there only for two or
three years for the resume purpose
doesn't care too much about the long
term he's not gonna be there it's too
short-term oriented I don't like that
what I want to be a rental that company
I say that because it compared that to a
rental car and people always give me a
hard time with that but I know that some
people I'm sure not here I'm sure that's
cool in the east that's the way they
think okay that when you rent the car
they have that thing don't be gentle
it's a rental
and then East they say that not here so
people who rental cars they they try
things that they don't trying their own
cars like going up a speed bump and see
if the four wolves will go up you know
and then they'll and
crash Bank why'd they do that because
somebody else will live with the
consequence of their driving in their
own car in our own car it's gonna be
ours this year the next five years next
ten years we're not gonna do that
because we're gonna live in the
consequences so we don't like people to
come to our company as a rental company
we're likely to GTO a company like the
owned company and if at some point of
the careers they ask the question oh you
know what I think it I'm at a point in
my career where I should go and try
something that's my own company then we
failed because the environment we have
in the company
it's a big start-up where everything
Foster's this idea that this is my
company that's why wealth creation and
linked to results so important I was
compared with the bakery we have a
bakery in Whole Foods open you know
across the street
and you had that bakery for three
generations nights under my watch
Austin Whole Foods open up selling bread
for a tenth of the price of my bread I
know it's not same quality but they say
consumers don't care and it's a one stop
shop for everything two ideas here if
you are an executive of the bakery you
say know what let me cross the street
and go work for work for Whole Foods
because they are winning if you're the
winner if you are the owner of the
bakery you're gonna say
times have changed I need to change
competitive environment has changed I
need to change what I offered to
consumers I know them better than Whole
Foods because I've been here for three
generations I know their names their
kids everything I know what they need to
shop because I can ask them I can have
here their baskets 20 items as opposed
to just bread I can be more of a
convenience store in and out in five
minutes over there it's half an hour in
lines and parking lots and everything
and I can beat this guy with the
knowledge I have that's an honor but for
that my salary roll down 20% I have to
cut my vacation for two years reinvest
in the business and then compete with
them failure is not an option
that's the difference between an owner
and an executive so ownerships key other
things that we have in our culture that
are very important that people like you
love the whole idea of healthy
dissatisfaction you're gonna do
something that's best in class best gets
defined redefined everyday so as long as
you get to a threshold yes or celebrate
you know how you're celebrating our
company when we reach a threshold a
milestone you say yeah that's great okay
next that's it because the moment you
get so convinced that you're the best
and that you've got there and that's it
that's the beginning the end that's why
that thing that dream big but stay
humble the other thing is face the
brutal facts consumers face the brutal
facts when consumers go with their
wallets to buy products beer
they give me a message every day of who
they don't they don't you know sugarcoat
they face reality why shouldn't we in
the company not face reality
why should we have the feel-good
department open you need to face reality
what's working let's do more of it
what's not working let's not let's
change let's call it the problem let's
call it a gap a gap that we need to
close another thing is focus on results
that's another thing that average
companies get confused look at this in a
company what you should reward is
results not efforts efforts you
recognize you acknowledge it's important
for career progression and yes normally
great results can't come with great
efforts but not necessarily the truth is
the same companies when they go buy
their products they don't buy efforts
they buy results can you imagine you put
a package on the shelf saying well this
is the this is a package that represents
six months of effort from this team you
know we work really 24/7 guys it was
amazing you know we did all this we
didn't get anywhere but this is the
final product of our effort consumers
don't buy that they buy results and
that's very hard because some companies
that don't have results they stoop a
bonus they still celebrate and that's
again beginning of the end leaders
celebrate when they have what to
celebrate they call it the problem in a
gap when there is a gap and they
recognize and acknowledge effort but
they reward results
so think about means and ends what
sqeeze ends means they're only good if
they get you to the end faster quick or
cheaper they need to exist otherwise the
ends are not replicable but means by
itself
no it's about ends your the things that
stay lean a leader of a high-performance
company is always worried about staying
lean
just like my life stay healthy because
when you're lean in situations are good
that's okay
but when situation turns bad like 2008
and you're lean you have more of a
condition to survive first and to
compete and to take advantage the best
deals we've done as a company was in
countries that were having issues and a
lot of foreigners were leaving we're
coming in not because we're mattress or
anything but because we take a long term
view of the business and we say okay
it's up but I'll have ups and downs and
that country's having it down here a bad
year but that country the fundamentals
are there not changed because of a bad
year so let's go in in the last thing
before I open for Q&A is that no
shortcuts that's very key to keep a
culture that works and instills high
performance and supports the big dream
and supports great people to come and
stay I once interviewed Jim Collins who
used to be a professor here we're very
connected to him as a company and I
interviewed him and I asked him if your
book good to great is a recipe book on
how companies based on research not your
opinion
go from good to great how come so many
companies don't read the book and just
like a cake or you know do it you know
and he said Britta according to my
research most companies start with good
intentions but then because they are in
a hurry
executives professionals not owners
they're in a hurry they jump stages so
instead of developing their own people
they hire from the market we're
developing people from within we like to
get people like you to join us
undergrad to join us and yes takes five
seven years to get somebody to be really
up to that level that you need but then
that person is part of the group is that
engaged group of owners not that selfish
bunch of executives and professionals
trying to build a resume we hate that
for
when I go to talk to two people like
huge students there's one thing that all
my colleagues hate when I say but I'm
gonna say it as a leader I cannot
promise fun in my company and then
everybody leaves the other tour I'm not
a native speaker as you can see I'm
Brazilian so fun for me has always been
a word in English that I quite did not
understand because fun for me is being
at the beach with my kids that's fun but
in the company expects much more than
fun I cannot promise fun hundreds at a
time because one of the things that the
leader should do to get performance is
to put pressure in the system will work
much better than the pressure think
about the condemned --ax when you have
an exam pressure you perform you study
you cramp everything you go there you
focus you do it the best you can you
have ahead of you there right I can
promise fashion which ramiz is much more
boring than fun compromise development
growth learning be excited that's what I
can promise dynamic leap frogging steps
and career funny yes when we achieved
results back and I promise 100% of time
other companies promise that and yes
they become an average company because
if you go to a place where you have fun
all the time there's no pressure and
without pressure there's no performance
we all perform under pressure much
better so the whole thing about no
shortcuts is this it takes a long time
to build a great company only owners can
do it professionals cannot do it and
I'll be right you to think about those
things let me open up for questions
thank you very much
[Applause]
all right we'll wash some audience here
hi mr. Brito my name is Miho thanks
first of all thanks for sharing with us
your thoughts my question is in regards
to how do you actually ensure that your
company and the people there in the
company live by those principles day in
day out you know how do you make sure
that they did not become complacent and
they understand the principles but then
at some point they kind of you know like
fall short and and you know did not
follow them well because of I travel a
lot so do my other leaders in the
company we have targets that are
stretched targets you know that really
put pressure on people and people that
don't really like that they can put up
with that for one year or two years and
then at some point they saying what I
never found anybody who said if you're
trying to build as a leader a high
performance company those things are
wrong never met anybody like that in all
the acquisitions and things we did but
I've met people that said you know what
given this stage of my life and my other
interests I'm not willing to do it
the same thing as a maritime high drug I
don't run marathons because I'm not
willing to put up the training that time
you know I don't want to do it you know
so I drug I don't run marathons we're
looking for the guys that run marathons
and some guys are joggers and it's fine
but not here so when we go recruit an
interview we try to be very clear about
what we do about about how we do things
then much more than what we do so people
understand that they're joining a group
of people that are trying to do
something that's best-in-class it will
never be perfect
we have many gaps that's why we need
people like you to join us and help us
close those gaps so we can open the next
gap but that's the direction that's the
the power of a dream yes question here
okay one thing I forgot to say is that
the best way to develop people within
the company then I'll go back to your
question is to get them constantly out
of their comfort zone
all of us will grow big time once we get
taken out of our comfort zone
some companies you enter finest you go
all the way your career in finest and
your company's exact just like when you
came to the just be a now to your
question when I came to GSB I came from
Brazil where I was the top student in
every place I went to you know my high
school my engineering school I was
always the top five top ten
I came to the GSB I was average okay
I was average and I was like oh my god
that was important to me because it
opened the gap to me my gap was closed
because I said you know what here or him
the screws I go and I went to the best
schools in my country
I was stopped I was not looking hard
enough I think I did when I decided to
come to decided to apply at least to
just be and they accepted me but that
opened the gap to me
and I said man the world is much
different than I thought it was so GSP
helps help me big time on that second
thing it helped me is the idea of
excellence I think here every trying
everybody's trying from the faculty to
the students to do something that's
excellence that's best-in-class in
companies that you guys are starting
ideas discussion groups I mean here you
have Nobel Prize Nobel Prize winners
teaching you I mean you know you come
with this idea that good is not good
enough it's it gotta be excellent
because it can be okay so and the third
thing is the power of ideas that's also
something I didn't know this idea that
when you have a powerful idea you can
get people to really come with you and
you can get a group to do much more than
they thought they could because you had
this powerful vision powerful idea and I
think here Business School
exposed to many of them so really opened
my gap big time and I never looked back
I'm still trying to close that gap by
the way and I was like very lucky that I
was here in 1989 1987 because if I were
to apply it today I'm pretty sure I
wouldn't be here like you are so the up
to game big time here - hi my name is
Rachel thank you so much you talked
about yourself to companies right here
okay you talked about looking at
companies and other industries that are
better than you guys are whether it be
at legal marketing supply chain could
you give us some examples of the
companies that you're trying to learn
from hmm in the old days when we're
trying or our people compensation system
will look a lot about a lot because of
the partnership structure
we'll look we look at companies like
Goldman Sachs 20 years ago when there
was - a private partnership not today a
public company in those days they had a
lot of the things that we learned from
in terms of being frugal you know be
very cost conscious because we are
because mine is so hard to make that we
try to tell our people guys let's spend
money and a very careful way because
very hard to make money in the first
place and if we're here all working for
the consumer let's see what's important
for him are and everything else is up
for grabs
so if ABCD is what they really pay a
premium for buy more off get more
loyalty will get more Wildtree from them
let's do more this and the non-working
money let's question so Walmart was a
big inspiration then Pepsi the whole
thing about leadership we learned a lot
about Pepsi so just three examples of in
the old days when we're putting this
stuff together companies that we look
for for for hints by the way our company
is a collection of things we copied from
everybody we didn't create anything and
we're very proud of that by the way we
copy with pride the only thing we did a
little twist wasn't the people side
because we thought was so important in
our culture in some way so unique that
we did a cup
twisting everything we just copied and
I've been in the company since the very
beginning so I can pretty much in sales
where I spend most of my time tell you
everything all the best practice we have
and the frameworks we use from which
company which year in that visit that we
saw that thing that we copied that we
got the manual that we adapted to our
situation so we copy everything but on
people we try to invest much more time
than the average company would do or
even this companies that we visited and
especially on the routine how can we
build a place where these people love
and will stay that's my number one
priority another question here I think
it's by by by staying humble I don't
know if I understood your question
correctly so you're saying how do you
avoid as you grow to go over pain oh
good I mean we have a toolkit we have a
toolkit of things that are developed
along the way because we've done many
acquisitions but if you look at
transnational you know different
continents six and every time in the
last ten years and every time we we get
more tools than that toolkit so what we
do is that we have a clue because we'd
be very lucky that we've been acquiring
things that's in our own industry so you
have a whole bunch of metrics that you
come and you say okay that's what's
expected from this business it's not a
diversification type business that you
go into total different business you can
get hurt so we go and we say okay this
is the way this business should be run
so therefore these are the synergies
that should be there lots of things in
procurement lots of things on
duplication of structures because we
have the the global teams that can do
things that the standalone company had
to do themselves so and we'd put a limit
to ourselves
we're very disciplined you only know of
the things we did but there are many
things that we passed that we said no no
it's beyond our limit our you know what
we put as a trash
and there's no better to be creative how
RIT was never too big to be big was to
be best in what we're doing and we'll
never get there because best is one of
those things that keeps getting rid to
find every day it's a neverending story
that's why every three years we do a KPI
of the dream their dream is to be the
best in what we do but because that will
never we'll never get there every three
years we'll say if we were to continue
along this journey and given the
situation competitive or because we
acquired this company and isn't that for
the next three years this is a subtle
KPI KPI s' indicators that will orient
us and then once you achieve those
sometimes we achieve earlier sometimes
takes another year never endure the way
you planned it it's always because
things change but the target remains
then when your chief is said okay now
for the next three years what are the
next things that we'll be sure that
we'll continue to be on that path
because you'll never get there because
it keeps getting rid of fine another
question yes hi first of all thank you
for the wisdom it's wonderful wonderful
thoughts I really appreciate it I'm
interested in the one company one
culture idea especially as you're
crossing borders with companies that are
hundreds of years old I mean they a good
question they are very proud of their
legacy and their history and the culture
that built it and yet you're saying that
was wonderful now you're belong to us
assimilate to the board or or what so
I'm learning about turnover I'm
wondering about how you retain that now
your question very good question and
that's that let's key guys because
that's where a lot of people get
distracted there are two things you have
the national culture of countries of
regions and you have the company culture
two different things we don't want to
change the national culture we can't do
it and the beauty of the world is that
people are different so you go to China
they dress differently their past time
is different their food is different
they have landmarks that are different
that's so beautiful then you go to India
you go to Brazil go to Belgium go to
Germany you go to Canada go to the US
even in the same country different
regions that's all beautiful and that's
why the world is so interesting one
thing we said from the very beginning is
that if you join our company
that's we called the ten principles 102
on people 7 on culture 10 in good and
bad times they don't change those are
the principles so if you like them great
we're not gonna change them and that
causes turnover yes but fine because it
takes 20 years 30 years a lifetime to
get the fabric to to be one a strong one
and it can destroy that by studying
being flexible and starting believing
things you go to Korea and people say oh
no every printer here is different
there's all idea of targets and
compensation for example tell you when
we came to the US because we believed in
the ownership our long-term incentive
okay its five-year vest so for you to do
that get the shares it's a five-year
vesting period the company we acquired
in the US was three years
given that the one-third would rest in
the first year the second third in the
second the third and the third you said
forget it
that's that short term that's not long
term call it something else if you're
gonna be here for 30 years what's five
years ours is five sometimes ten years
cliff so if you live four years 11
months zero it's five years and a lot of
people left because of that for example
I travel commercial and yes because I
travel to Russia China India and all
that it in a way one could picture as a
waste of time
but that's important for the culture
because then when I ask her people guys
we're in a tough year we need you guys
to to buckle up and to really stretch
things and really give your best because
it's a tough year and find non-working
money so we can invest behind the work
your money I can say it because they
travel commercial I stay in the same
hotel as everybody stays they stay in
the same hotels all I do I eat the same
thing they eat everything is the same I
need more money than they do
we're not socialists
okay no but on the silly things we hate
anything that's the status symbol
we think that destroys the whole idea of
a group and engage group so I don't have
a company car I don't have a driver I
don't have an office I don't have a jet
I'm just like all my colleagues and yes
it takes at all but it's worth for the
culture which is much bigger and the
culture is the one that gives us the
performance which I'm here for then it's
a full circle but again this idea of
national culture so what Japan is
different but if you Japanese call it
want to join a company you have to buy
into this concepts and by the way what
we say is that you have to have a big
dream surround yourself with the best
people can find and create an
environment where they stay look at Mike
Phelps he had the same idea he wanted to
have a gold medals why eight all of us
would be happy with one you want a late
dream he surrounded himself with the
best people he could find coaches
exercise people everything in he own the
process here's one being forced to do it
he was doing this and during his
birthday Christmas Day New Year's
because you wanted so the prince was
apply to any good student here at the
GSP to any good athlete and we believe
to the company too so we're not asking
anything that's out of the ordinary it's
all common sense but because it's common
sense people don't talk about it they
take it for granted and that's why it
doesn't work that's diluted so one
company one culture never buy to the
situation oh no here it doesn't work
no no we've tried before trust me it
doesn't work don't buy it because then
if cultures to do a performance and you
dilute it your performance will suffer
and as a leader again you're there to
generate results with the people do it
the right way another question last
question I'm a second year MBA student
my name is Alex thank you for coming I
want to say here at the GSB we're big
consumers of your products so thank you
that said that's and I've included in
that but that said I don't want to
ignore all the harm that alcohol does
call does cause in the world it is a
drug and a harmful one at that Harvard
just released a 75 year longitudinal
study citing alcohol as the primary
factor for relating to unhappiness and
in life and I want to ask you how you
deal with the implication the ethical
implications of your question running
this up anyway good question first I
think any product is engineered and
thought for something and then people
can always misuse it think about cars
how many accidents are on the roads and
cars were thought to be what means of
transportation to go from A to B but
some people use it as a racing track as
a racing thing think about
pharmaceuticals drugs think about
tylenol in some countries you cannot
sell pollen all in the way it's sell
here in the US because if you take 20
you kill yourself because your liver
stops but the guy inside of tylenol was
for a headache for a back pain but if
you take 20 you die of course the same
thing the same way there studies proving
what you said there are many studies
that says including many countries
alcohol is part of the healthy diet that
governments tell people they should do
nobody's saying you should start if you
don't drink it but if you drink it in
moderation that's good for many things
governments say that so again we are
against misuse of alcohol and we've been
working I remember in Brazil 15 years
ago we gave breathalyzers to the Highway
Patrol because they didn't have the
money to buy it and I remember being
interviewed in the press and people say
in a Brit oh you want to sell more beer
and you give breathalyzers to people -
you know - the Highway Patrol how does
that connect and I say look at our per
capita consumption here compared to
other countries
those other countries have a higher per
capita consumption but they do it rights
and the accidents are way lower compared
to ours so there's a clear opportunity
here to designate a driver to use it in
moderation to use more cab services and
with support of all that for example if
you go to a music event of ours today
anywhere in the world and you drive and
at the end you had two or three beers
and you don't feel like driving back
we'll provide your free parking with
security transportation and you can come
the next day and get your car again I'm
not saying with perfect guys
I'm just saying all industries have
harmed for use okay I'm just saying as
an industry we've always said we don't
need that and we tried to partners with
people that can enforce the laws because
we can't so they have the means to go
after people that are doing that on the
other hand a B the company were acquired
here has been a visionary on that has
been working on responsible drinking
since the eighties and government
statistics in the u.s. say government
statistics not ours they've been
measuring for 30 years
they say that drink and drive access in
the US are at an all-time low
in underage drinking all-time low
their statistics pick why because what
works is education and targeted
intervention it's not increasing taxes
restricting distributions because the
moment you do do this you create a grey
market so the way to do it like anything
driving how do you teach your kid to
drive I mean you take the kid you know
it this is not a racing track this thing
gets caught you can kill people and then
maybe you have a kid that will be
responsible I'll cause the same thing
drugs the same thing you know time
anything so I think anything can have a
misuse can be misused but our business
is mostly based on the way it was
thought to get people together
can you imagine celebration at least in
our culture without an alcoholic
beverage or food that was an ad by a B
in the 80s where there was a graduation
party and everybody was celebrating with
carrots
if everybody was slowly brain we care
it's okay graduate it's alright don't
get that's toast and then Huck Huck
well let's celebrate now that we
graduated from Stanford Business School
let's have water everybody will have
water or juice can't imagine that no so
that's what we're for
that's how beer was created but yes just
like automobiles just like farming
industry some people luckily I might
already will use it in strange ways and
we're totally against it and if I have
more time I can explain
we're actually actually a report that's
online saying of all the initiatives
that we do and you can all say can do
more always we can do more but you know
at least we have a position in we're
doing things thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]